Governor Abbott in Texas who was sitting
on the fence he wasn't going to pick a
candidate he's just come out now he
endorses Trump we need a president who's
going to secure the Border we need a
president who's going to restore Law and
Order in the United States of America
not letting these criminals run rans
sack over the stores that you see images
of almost night nightly we need a
president who's going to restore World
Peace as opposed to this outbreak of
warfare under Joe Biden we need Donald J
Trump back as our president of the
United States of America I'm here today
to officially Proclaim my endorsement
for Donald J Trump to be president of
the United States of America again there
he is okay so you're seeing
consolidation and that will probably
continue I'm not saying to sandis is out
of the race yet but the question is what
is going to change the momentum here